now I then saw this over the weekend and
this is one of those no kidding
statistics you see the statistic you go
no kidding
well check this out
11.27 million barrels a day you know
what that is
crude oil and refined products refined
products gasoline heating oil
um aviation fuel Avgas
11.27 million barrels a Dale are
exported of crude oil and crude oil
products by United States
let me say that again exported
and that is an all-time high let's take
a look at this chart I'm pulling it up
still
and
meanwhile production of crude being
pulled out of the ground Rose to record
highs in March
with Drillers pumping out 12.7
million barrels a day and you say wait
this doc what's going on I thought we
bought all of our oil from the Middle
East no Surrey
we do not buy all of our oil from the
Middle East
and we are an oil power so wait a minute
if the United States is at an all-time
high of exporting who are we exporting
to well Canada buys a lot from us
um a lot of people buy from us
well I don't understand I thought you
know we're worried about the Saudis not
pumping oil and stuff like that well we
are
um
well why all the media fuss about oil
and about pipelines and about the Saudis
okay about OPEC well let me explain
something
if the United States is an oil power we
are more independent and we are more
um
crisis proof on the world stage because
we can handle our own stuff we drove out
of um
Texas and there's a type of oil when
you'll see the price of oil for WTI that
stands for West Texas intermediate
that's a type of oil there's also light
sweet crude they talk a lot about Saudi
oil light sweet crude also talk about
North Sea Brent Brent crude those are
just types of oil just think of it as
oil
and
the World Market for oil is very complex
but the United States the more we become
entered fully energy independent and we
actually are an exporter what happens is
that gives us independent and that's not
what the green lobby wants and the
globalist ones the globalists in the
green lobby are together in two things
globalists want the U.S to be part of a
new world order and and to come Together
We Are Family Kumbaya and we all know
what the globalists want right complete
destruction of sovereignty One One World
Government the whole bit well how do you
get there if the United States is oil
independent and the minute you have any
moderate or conservative presidents
congresses or Senate to United States
you're not going to get a site you don't
you don't you will not as they say
get the United States put over a barrel
for that it's not going to happen so
being oil independent energy independent
works against the globalists
um desires for the United States the
other people that it works against is
the greens the greens want all fossil
fuel to be stopped tomorrow and
California puts in Things by 2030 all
new cars have to be sold or electric or
whatever it was they did yeah well now
go try to overnight plug all those
electric cars into California the grid
shorts out and more and more wildfires
are started yeah because Dirty Little
Secret California
their infrastructure for energy is
terrible it's outdated
so then Saudi comes out because the
price of oil
see the price of oil has been sliding
down and I don't have this one can you
find that Kai
um a oil oil pricing charge yeah average
price of crude and let's go back one
year
so we'll see what's going on here
so the price of oil has been gently
coming down along with inflation getting
under control remember it's not there
yet it's just gone from 9.1 down to here
so you go one year take a look at that
so in is is that January January June
8th this January we we welcome the new
year I think with 115 dollar oil
something like that wasn't it you're
saying 76 for crude oil
Futures oh yeah it was a year ago a year
ago 22. you rang in the New Year in 22
at about 115.
22 Yeah 22 is expensive
22 started off at 78 but then it went up
to
1 15 in March and 22. yep so it was end
of first quarter yep
life runs so fast I can't remember yeah
so take a look that's what's happening
in the crew so
there you have it you know you've got
the price coming down a little bit now
Saudi says we're going to cut production
because they want to raise the price of
their crude uh on a national scale so
what does that mean for us well that
means that in the midst of inflation
getting under control the Saudis want to
actually cause the price of oil to be
less under control because the Saudis
are in it for themselves so they want to
get oil prices to go up now a dirty
little secret is sometimes the U.S oil
producers go straight to that price as
well and they make money just like
anybody else yeah when they have those
cartels and the osec yeah and well and
the Chevrons and the exons who if you
take a look in the middle of covid
Chevron exxron had record profits yep in
the middle of the and so we can have the
debate about price gouging here another
time but what it means is right now is
still a time for you to be running the
best business you can treating your
people well keeping the great people
trimming trimming off the the other
people because there's the opportunity
to do that and come out on the other
side stronger than you got here so
that's the way I see it
foreign